welcome to this video playing for us
Ferris far I don't know from france
french flag and i played the sicilian
let's see what what happens many many
players nowadays prefab you should be 5
p.m. somehow as clock is not ticking my
hope birth oops I don't have a solo
connection I know I have no no it's all
again ok but I have lost some time at
least I didn't lose the game due to a
connection ok but should be 5 and 10
yeah he took on c6 this is a popular way
to play I think even f5 as a line yeah
come on I only hope that he's not an
expert because i only know that this
exists and is risky but playable I hope
that is not um it's not just rattling
off some theoretical moves here to to
crush me this is really looking
dangerous black I'm pretty sure it is ok
but hmm yeah the King the king on only
eight
yeah this is a very very ambitious way
to play as black so Knight f6 probably
plays every mmm i'm going to play I need
to need to anticipate what to do against
f3 knight f6f three of them I take Quinn
takes this looks wow very ugly c6
hanging f5 hanging not not even playable
I guess okay so I could I could play d 5
I would still that's a three
I don't know what's what's the right
move here maybe something like Queen f6
but this further cranks up my
development all right let's create a
text d 4 so that f3 I can take with
check yeah this could be a great quick
disaster it has all the ingredients for
a quick loss I'm not not developed well
and it's all all very shaky hmm yeah and
now he's yes a protected deform hmm
yeah I don't really see what else it's
clear that that I'm on the ropes here
how do i get at least some development
yeah I need to get the Queen Queen
somewhere try it for g6 Bishop g7 but I
probably won't survive this anyway 95 is
very very ugly for me yeah and it's not
even difficult
trying to play Queen before I can just
play a three I probably would play a
three here now simple simple and good
yeah Bishop f4 can also take g6
I don't even see a move maybe age 65
fights it's it's just it's just a
disaster
now 96 just one of the ways to to play
actually more complicated than I thought
check it's it's winning night of 70 yeah
just night f7 okay or this one this
doesn't doesn't look great either now
it's just this is P saying yeah okay
let's put it like this resigns yeah okay
probably shouldn't play such a sharp
line if you don't know it especially if
you are if you are so far behind in
development I know that this is this is
playable but how exactly do you play
here you are Queen f6 um yeah I had my
doubts I had my doubts bought this move
but what do you do here I wasn't really
am coming to grips with this position
Jim didn't really see what to do here
maybe you can't do that I mean it's
maybe you can play that but how do you
develop now not this one queen is oops
attacking d6 and d7 no it's not it's
it's not comfortable yeah and this I
really don't see how to how to play this
here may I cannot take here this is a
this is disastrous I don't have any
development so yeah it's clear that I'm
violating some principles here
so you can only justify it with some
concrete ideas and I didn't find them in
the in the numerator time the computer
wants to play that which I cannot
believe really i mean this is cleared it
supports egg giving up the three ball
and it says that black has some
compensation maybe yeah but this I
couldn't couldn't peel a yeah with a
port now this this now is is really bad
but he punished it nicely a free it's
not difficult but all very
straightforward flame Jeremy yeah I this
is that lost computers on minus four
already here here a three is the the
most forceful move but it's winning
anyway just preventing queen before okay
yet it's it's multi i thot 97 this is
also winning everything winds check what
a disaster so I'm probably I shouldn't
have played this this thing with at five
Blake doesn't need to do that you can
play Knight f6 and I have a relatively
normal position and five is playable but
not to hit in the way I I did alright
thanks for watching